This is a quick overview on the concept of velocity,
which is more or less the same as the concept of derivative,
which could be called rate of change in general terms.
If you are already acquainted with that, you may want to skip to the quiz.
Imagine this situation: that we have a high-speed train on the track
that is labeled from -100 km to +100 km.
So the track is 200 km long.
And this is our timetable.
The train starts here at -100 km, and drives at a pretty high speed
'til 1½ hours after the start.
Then it stops at this position, 50 km.
It continues somewhat slower for 1 hour, 'til it reaches that position at +100 km.
Then it immediately returns to the position x = 0,
4 hours after it started.
This is, if you will, a mathematical view of the train's time table.
Let's rotate this by 90° to get something that's more typical for physics.
So now I've taken this diagram and rotated it by 90°
to come up with that diagram.
The t-axis now points to the right, and the x-axis now points upward.
We can create a second diagram from that that shows the velocity.
So here the train advances at 100 km/h, here it's just 50 km/h.
Here the train goes backward with 100 km/h.
So maybe a good idea is to label this axis with +100 km/h and -100 km/h.
So here we have a velocity of +100 km/h, here too,
and then the train stops, which means we have a velocity of 0.
And here the train starts again and makes 50 km/h
which is just half as much as before.
And here we are going backward with 100 km/h as its speed,
so the velocity is -100 km/h.
This is what the velocity looks like.
So if you're going forward, it's positive, if you're going backward, its negative.
So what we see here is the velocity of the train, depending on time.
That's nothing but the rate of change of the position, which we call x,
by how much does x change if a certain amount of time passes.
The rate of change would be the ratio.
For instance, this ratio: 100 km divided by 1 hour -- the velocity of 100 km/h.
In this case, the ratio would be 50 km divided by 1 hour; 50 km/h.
So what we are drawing here is the rate of change of the x position,
nothing but the velocity, and this is the very same as the derivative.
The derivative tells us the local rate of change.
Here the derivative is 100 km/h, here it's 0, here it's 50 km/h, and here it's negative.
As the time advances, the x position decreases.
A negative derivative, negative velocity, negative rate of change.
The standard way of writing that: v of t, the velocity depending on t.
One way of writing it is dx of t by dt, or x prime of t,
or, and this is what the physicists are using, x dot of t.
I'm going to stick to that notation.
Whenever physicists want to compute the rate of change
with respect to time, they put a dot on top of that variable.